the CEO of the shoe company Birkenstock
is squaring off with the online retail
giant Amazon Birkenstock is fighting a
new Amazon program where it buys
products from third priority merchants
and then sells them on its website
Birkenstock pulled its products from
Amazon earlier this year and in the
email obtained by The Washington Post
Birkenstock CEO wrote to the shop owners
quote I share in no uncertain terms that
this is unacceptable and will not be
tolerated any authorized retailer who
may do this for even a single pair will
be closed forever
I repeat forever we reached out to
Birkenstock but they declined to comment
about this lee gallagher is a senior
editor at large at Fortune magazine you
got lots of comment about today it seems
to me that the CEO Birkenstock David GaN
and Jeff Bezos the head cheese over at
Amazon will not be having lunch anytime
soon I think this is interesting because
in this five-page email
David Gahan says this is a middle finger
to all brands yes so this is about why
did they pull their shoes in the first
place back up a little the company and
this is the u.s. CEO it's a german
company and he pulled the products from
amazon because of concerns over
counterfeit goods that were being really
you know he was concerned that they
weren't there were too many counterfeit
goods there from third-party retailers
this is an issue that many brands have
with amazon he pulled them now amazon is
a hundred thousand percent focused only
on the consumer and so they went and
bought up Birkenstocks from other
retailers and put them on their site to
sell them so that when you and I go to
Birkenstock which I actually did
yesterday on Zappos calm which is oh my
Amazon and I bought a pair of Berkut
socks but you know they're still there
and and he's buying them on the open
marketplace from other retailers now
Amazon does not make a penny when they
do that because they're buying and
selling them for retail but they don't
care because they just want to please
the consumer and that's how they've
gotten so big so now he's saying any of
his existing retailers so even a single
pair boy so big is right Anton has
joined the 500 billion dollar club in
terms of market cap along with Microsoft
half a trillion dollars that's pretty
amazing
yeah that's an earnings later today yes
and they're in every everything now and
this is how they do it I mean they
you know for years story in Amazon's
that they were not making a profit but
they didn't care because they were just
pursuing gross but it's just cutting off
your nose to spite your face in some
respects it is I mean it's actually
bucking a trend that's happening
Birkenstocks a private company so they
can afford to do this but other big
brands I'm actually going in the other
direction and coming to the reality that
you cannot you're doing yourself a
disservice if you're not on Amazon
because of the you know hundreds of
millions of eyeballs that you can sell
to there so Nike which didn't sell it on
Amazon for a long time just recently
said you were gonna sell the Amazon
Kenmore is now selling on Amazon the CEO
of gap last year as my colleague Phil
Waddell reported said that it would be
delusional to not consider here is what
Amazon said about this while sellers can
opt out at any time this offers
customers a widening selection of great
brands that's the thing they just care
about what the customer wants and that's
why they're looking at drone delivery
that's why they're they wanted to make
it as easy as possible that's why you
can get something in an hour I mean all
of this is incredibly you know costing a
lot of money to offer all these things
and and but that doesn't matter they
want to please us and delight us
Birkenstock is talking about legal
action we'll see they are we'll see
about that it'll be an interesting case
study even though it's a smaller example
alright thank ya very much you so much
for being here